This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's almost that time... ...for the Olympics. The pageantry, the dreams, breathtaking victories... ...for fans, it's an event of extraordinary drama. Athletes from across the globe competing at the very highest level at the limits of human endurance. Social scientists find the games equally compelling for what they reveal about human behavior.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。差不多又是那个时候了……奥林匹克运动会又要来了。盛大的场面、梦想、叹为观止的胜利……对粉丝来说，这是一场非凡戏剧性的活动。来自全球的运动员在整个人类耐力极限的最高水平上竞争。社会科学家发现，这些比赛同样引人入胜，因为它们揭示了人类的行为。
When a match ends, the winners and losers do something. That's immediate, automatic, it's unconscious, they have no control of it, it just happens. About a second later, then they come to their senses and they realize that they're on stage. And whatever rules they've learned to manage their expressions kick in then. Coming up, what the Olympics can teach us about human behavior, from a professor who's also an Olympic judo coach. Stay with us. My guest today is David Matsumoto. He's a professor of psychology at San Francisco State University.
当比赛结束时，赢家和输家会做出一些举动。那是即时的、自动的、无意识的，他们无法控制，它就那样发生了。大约一秒钟后，他们才回过神来，意识到自己正身处舞台之上。然后，他们为管理表情而学到的任何规则便开始发挥作用。接下来，我们将从一位同时也是奥运柔道教练的教授那里，探讨奥运会能教给我们关于人类行为的什么启示。请继续收听。我今天的嘉宾是戴维·马苏莫托。他是旧金山州立大学的心理学教授。
He's used the Olympics as a laboratory for psychological observations. But he's also been a part of the Olympics. David's coach the US Olympic judo team and his daughter has competed in the games. I'm going to talk to him today first about his research and then about what a sharp I'd psychologist might observe about human behavior at the games. David, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. You photographed 84 athletes from 34 countries who were competing in
他曾将奥运会用作心理学观察的实验室。但他也是奥运会的一部分。戴维曾执导过美国奥运柔道队，他的女儿也曾参加过奥运会。今天我将首先与他讨论他的研究，然后讨论一个敏锐的心理学家在奥运会上可能会对人类行为有什么观察。戴维，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。你拍摄了来自34个国家的84名运动员，他们参加了
the 2004 Athens Olympics judo competitions and you photographed them at the moments when they won or lost their matches. What did you find? Well, what you find is that people all around the world show exactly the same types of expressions depending upon whether they want to loss. So those who won a match or won a medal, for example, invariably showed some kind of enjoyment smile. And those who lost the last match showed nothing sometimes. Some of them showed sadness.
2004年雅典奥运会的柔道比赛，你在他们比赛获胜或落败的瞬间拍摄了他们。你发现了什么？嗯，你发现的是，世界各地的人们根据他们是赢是输，会表现出完全相同的表情。例如，那些赢得比赛或赢得奖牌的人，总是会表现出某种愉快的微笑。而那些输掉最后一场比赛的人有时什么也不表现出来。他们中的一些人表现出悲伤。
Some of them showed some kind of distress. But the interesting thing about these findings is that those patterns vary depending upon whether they won or lost, but they'd not vary across any of the countries or cultures that the athletes came from. Now most laypeople would not necessarily be surprised by this. They would sort of say, yeah, sure people win, they sort of look the same, but why is this interesting from a scientific perspective? Well, it's interesting because actually before our study, there were many, many studies that
他们中的一些人表现出某种痛苦。但这些发现有趣的地方在于，这些模式会根据他们是赢是输而变化，但不会随着运动员来自的国家或文化而变化。现在，大多数外行人不一定会对这一点感到惊讶。他们可能会说，是的，当然人们赢了，他们看起来差不多，但为什么从科学的角度来看这很有趣呢？嗯，这很有趣，因为实际上在我们的研究之前，有许许多多研究
have shown that similar types of patterns of findings, cross-cultural similarities in these expressions. But there was never a study that was done in what we call an ecologically valid environment out in the real world to show that people actually do this stuff in the real world outside of a psychology laboratory. And I was just very, very fortunate to be able to do this study at the Olympics, which is a perfect social psychological laboratory. In some ways, the study was basically making the argument, I suppose, that at least in the moment of triumph, people's reactions were shaped by what seemed
显示了类似类型的发现模式，即这些表情中的跨文化相似性。但从来没有一项研究是在我们所谓的生态有效环境中（即现实世界）进行的，以表明人们确实在心理学实验室之外的现实世界中做这些事情。而且我非常非常幸运能够在奥运会上进行这项研究，这是一个完美的社会心理学实验室。在某些情况下，这项研究基本上是在提出这样的论点，我想，至少在胜利的时刻，人们的反应是由那些看起来
like biologically innate imperatives. Yeah, that's exactly right. However, that study by itself fell a little short. So in actuality, we had the second study, which studied the Paralympic Athletes. And in every sport in the Paralympic says a different disability for judo, it's blindness. And so we compared the expressions of the blind athletes to those of the sighted athletes, and we found exactly the same things.
像生物学上天生的指令所塑造的。是的，完全正确。然而，该研究本身有点不足。因此实际上，我们进行了第二项研究，研究了残奥会运动员。残奥会中每个运动项目的残疾情况都不同，对于柔道而言，它是失明。因此，我们比较了盲人运动员与视力正常运动员的表情，我们发现了完全相同的事情。
So these are athletes who've been blind. Some of them presumably blind from birth. They presumably have... No, they haven't really... They make it even clearer than that. We had athletes who are congenitally blind. So blind from birth, there's no presumption about what they've seen. They've been impossible to see those expressions. And the fact that they produce the same things on their faces for certain emotions and then their bodies for triumph
所以这些都是失明的运动员。其中一些人大概是天生失明的。他们大概有……不，他们真的没有……我们让它变得更清楚。我们有先天失明的运动员。所以从出生起就是盲人，对于他们看过什么没有任何假设。他们不可能看到这些表情。事实上，他们在脸上针对某些情绪以及在身体上针对胜利做出了相同的反应
absolutely suggest that these things are biologically innate. What did the facial expression of triumph look like? Well triumph is actually a whole body response and involves the expansion of the chest, raising the hands, oftentimes with a fist, a little bit of fierce or aggressive look in the face and oftentimes a stern gaze at some kind of target. Now one of the things you found which I found really fascinating was yes you do find evidence that some of these expressions are biologically innate but you also find that culture plays
绝对表明这些事情是生物学上天生的。胜利的面部表情是什么样的？嗯，胜利实际上是一个全身的反应，它包括胸部的扩张、举起双手（通常握着拳头）、脸上带着一丝凶猛或好斗的表情，并且经常对准某个目标严厉注视。现在，你发现的其中一件事我发现真的非常迷人，那就是是的，你确实找到了证据表明其中一些表情是生物学上天生的，但你也发现文化在奥运会上扮演着
a huge role at the Olympics. Tell me about that part of the study. What we did was study the expressions across time. So even though we were using a camera, we were using a camera that was shooting eight photographs a second. And so across a number of seconds we can see how expression is transformed across time. So immediately when a match ends the winners and losers do something. That's immediate, automatic, it's unconscious, they have no control of it, it just happens.
巨大的角色。跟我讲讲研究的那部分。我们做的是研究跨时间的表情。所以即使我们用的是相机，我们使用的是每秒拍摄八张照片的相机。因此，在几秒钟内，我们可以看到表情如何随着时间而转变。因此，比赛一结束，赢家和输家就会做点什么。那是即时的、自动的、无意识的，他们无法控制，它就那样发生了。
About a second later, then they come to their senses and they realize that they're on stage. And whatever rules they've learned to manage their expressions, kick in then. And that's that second expression or third expression sometimes where you see these vast cultural differences. Some athletes are smiling, some athletes show nothing, some athletes start crying, some athletes do something else. But it's very interesting how you see the change at that point, but cultural invariance at the beginning. You find that even though you have this range of emotions that kicks in after the first second
大约一秒钟后，他们回过神来，意识到自己身处舞台上。无论他们学过什么规则来管理自己的表情，都会在那个时候开始起作用。这就是那种第二种表情或有时是第三种表情，你会看到这些巨大的文化差异。有些运动员在笑，有些运动员什么也不表现出来，有些运动员开始哭泣，有些运动员做别的事。但非常有趣的是，你如何看到那个时间点的变化，但开始时却具有文化不变性。你发现，尽管在第一秒或头几秒钟之后，你会发现这种情绪范围开始发挥作用，但这些并不是随机的。这些实际上在某些方面是由文化决定的，你确实发现来自某些国家的运动员表现出的行为与来自其他国家的运动员有可预测的不同。是的，我们后来能够识别出这种文化变异的各种模式。所以，有中和者。那些表现得像刻板印象一样什么都不表现出来的人，你可以选出东欧苏联集团或也是苏联集团的国家，东欧。那些其中带有一些共产主义历史的人，例如古巴就是这样的。你可以想到减弱者，那些表现出一些东西但被稍微淡化了一点的人。有很多北美
or the first couple of seconds, these are not random. These actually are in some ways culturally determined that you actually find athletes from certain countries behave predictably differently than athletes from other countries. Yes, we were able to identify the various patterns of that cultural variation later on. So, they're the neutralizers. Those who kind of show nothing as stereotypes, you can pick up Eastern Soviet block or also Soviet block countries, Eastern Europe. Those who have some communist history in them Cuba for example are like that. You can think of the de-amplifiers, those who show something but it's muted a little bit. There are a lot of North American
西方那种文化会这样做。还有那些在某些事情之后笑得很多的人，甚至是那些有消极事情的人，你可以想到东亚人就是这样的。所以是的，在文化调节的主要模式如何进行方面，存在着这些非常有趣的文化、地理变异。换句话说，人们表达了内心真正可能发生的事情，但随后文化介入了
western kind of cultures that do that. There's those that smile a lot after something, even those that have something negative, you can think of the East Asians as something like that. So yes, there's these very interesting cultural, geographic variations on how the major patterns go in the cultural regulation. So in other words, people express what really maybe is happening inside them, but then the culture kicks in
并说，这是你在这种情况下应该表现的方式。这正是它的本质。我们大多数人之所以看不到那种即时的反应，是因为当事情发生时，我们通常在看着发生的事情。因此，当我们看到事情发生在谁身上时，他们已经处于文化调节的部分了。正是像我们这样一直将相机对准那个人、观察即时反应的人，才能捕捉到即时反应。关于奥运会最著名的研究之一，我们在《隐藏的大脑》的其他地方做过专题报道。
and says, here's the way you off to behave in the situation. That's exactly what it is in that. And the reason why most of us don't see that immediate reaction is because when something happens, we're often looking at the thing that happened. So by the time we look at the person who it happened to, they're already on the cultural regulation part. And it's people like us who have a camera on that person all the time who are watching the immediate reactions, we can get the immediate reaction. One of the most celebrated studies looking at the Olympics, we featured at elsewhere in Hidden Brain.
这是康奈尔大学的托马斯·吉洛维奇与维多利亚·梅德韦克和斯科特·梅迪合作的一项研究。他分析了巴塞罗那奥运会上奖牌得主脸上的表情。他发现在巴塞罗那奥运会上，总的来说，铜牌得主看起来比银牌得主更高兴。他发现在总的来说，铜牌得主看起来比银牌得主更高兴。我要让你告诉我为什么会这样，以及你自己的研究是如何既放大又对该发现进行了细化补充的。
This is a study by Thomas Gillovich at Cornell, along with Victoria Medvek and Scott Medi. He analyzed the expressions on the faces of metal winners in the Barcelona Olympics. And he found that in general, bronze metal winners looked happier than silver metal winners in the Barcelona Olympics. And he found that in general, bronze metal winners looked happier than silver metal winners. I'm gonna let you tell me why that might be the case, but also how your own research both amplified and has a nuance to that finding.
嗯，我们发现了完全相同的事情。实际上，我们研究的伟大之处之一不仅在于我们能够研究运动员刚赢或刚输、刚在垫子上时的表情，我们还可以跟随他们在30分钟后的颁奖典礼上观察，所以我们看到同一个人取得了相同的结果，但现在社会背景不同了，而你完全说得对，银牌得主，领奖台上的每个人都在笑。所以这毫无疑问，因为
Well, we found exactly the same things. Actually, one of the great things about our study is that not only were we able to study the expressions of the athletes right when they wanna loss, right when they're on the mat, We could follow them 30 minutes later in the middle ceremony so we saw what the same person did who had the same result but it's now the social context is different and you're exactly right the silver medallists everybody on the podium smiles. So there's no question about it because
这是一件非常公开的电视转播的事情。但如果你测量微笑中移动的精确肌肉，你会发现，让我们把银牌得主的微笑称为更多的痛苦的微笑，因为他们身上发生了很多其他事情。你可以看到，你看不到眼角的褶皱。有时你会看到嘴唇向下弯曲，因为他们真的在努力控制
this is a very public televised thing. But if you measure the exact muscles that are moving in the smiles, you find that, let's call the silver metal smiles more of the miserable smile because they've got a lot of other things going on. You can see the, you won't see the crinkle in the eyes. Sometimes you'll see the downturning of the lips because they're really trying to control
一些负面情绪以及微笑。所以有些人在笑的时候看起来很痛苦。吉洛维奇会认为这是因为银牌得主在把自己和金牌得主进行比较，说如果我只快了半秒钟，如果我只跳得快一点，我本可以成为，我本可以成为金牌得主。
some negative feelings along with the smile. So some of them look miserable when they're smiling. And Gilevich would argue this is because a cell of metal winners are comparing themselves to the gold medal winners, saying if I only had gone half a second faster, if I'd only jumped a little bit faster, I could have been, I could be a gold medal winner.
完全正确。所以当你看到铜牌得主时，他们有更多理由更高兴，因为他们的备选项是什么也没有。而银牌得主，他们的备选项是金牌。所以在我们的研究中，我们还发现铜牌得主比银牌得主拥有更多快乐的微笑。我们对这个铜牌得主现象发现的唯一例外，当我回看我们的数据时，我认为非常有趣，那就是有些铜牌得主看起来并不是很高兴。
That's exactly right. And so when you get to the bronze medalist, they have more reason to be happier because the alternative is nothing. Whereas the silver medalist, the alternative was the gold. And so in our study, we also found that the bronze medalists had more of the enjoyment smiles than the silver medalists did. The only exceptions that we found to this bronze medalist thing that I thought was really interesting when I look back at our data, there are some bronze medalists who did not look very happy.
这些通常是前一年世界锦标赛的冠军，他们作为夺冠热门来到奥运会，但他们不得不满足于铜牌。因此，由于他们不得不满足于铜牌，他们并不像那些获得铜牌的人那样高兴。他们中的许多人没有期望获得奖牌，或者他们只是很高兴能获得奖牌。太迷人了。
And these were generally the winners of the world championships of the previous year who came into the Olympics as the favorite, and they had to settle for bronze. So because they had to settle for bronze, they were not as happy as those who are getting a bronze. And a lot of them didn't expect to get a medal or they were just happy to get a medal. Fascinating.
当我们回来时，我将询问戴维关于他自己参加奥运会的经历。以及心理学家从做教练和做奥运选手父母中可以学到什么。请继续收听。请让我大致了解一下奥运会柔道垫上运动员身上发生的事情的规模。我的意思是，从生理学上讲，这对他意味着什么？我会确切地告诉你发生了什么，因为我们实际上研究过这种事情。你知道，如果我们现在坐在这里进行这次对话，如果我们测量我们的心率，如果我们健康且正常，我们大概在60、72左右，因为我们现在正在做一些非常令人兴奋的事情，也许我们在80左右。如果你想象自己在慢跑，你可能处于最大心率的70%，根据你的年龄，可能是1.3、1.40。在柔道比赛中，我们实际测得运动员的心率约为每分钟200次。哇。这些是高度训练有素的运动员。你必须经过高度训练才能达到每分钟200次。这些是高度训练有素的运动员。高度，你必须经过高度训练才能达到每分钟200次。这是在战斗条件下的每分钟200次。现在，想想我在说什么。你将在战斗条件下达到每分钟200次，思路清晰，发挥出你的水平，
When we come back, I'm going to ask David about his own experience of the Olympics. And what a psychologist might learn from being a coach and being a parent of an Olympia. Stay with us. Give me some sense of the scale of what's happening in an athlete on the judo mad in the Olympics. I mean, physiologically, what's happening to that? I'll tell you exactly what's happening because we've actually studied this kind of thing. You know, if you and I are sitting down here right now having this conversation, if we clocked our heart rate, if we're healthy and normal, we probably about 60, 72, something
在技术、战略和其他所有方面都知道自己在做什么。要达到这一点并不容易。这不是我们坐下来就能谈论的事情。这不是我真正能坐在这里像传统心理学家那样帮助你的事情。说实话，我得让你真正进行体力活动。而且我必须训练你的身体来耐受随着我将你带到那个指标而你的身体产生的乳酸。
like that, since we're doing something that's really exciting right now, maybe we're at 80 or something. If you imagine yourself taking a jog, you might be at 70% of your max heart rate, which would maybe be at 1.3, 1.40 depending upon your age. In a judo match, we've actually clocked athletes heart rates around 200 beats a minute. Wow. And these are highly conditioned athletes. You've got to be highly conditioned to be at 200 beats a minute. And these are highly conditioned athletes. Highly, you've got to be highly conditioned to be at 200 beats a minute. And this is 200 beats a minute in combat conditions. Now, think about what I'm saying. You're going to be at 200 beats a minute in combat conditions, thinking clearly, being on your game,
作为教练，当运动员的身体处于高度亢奋状态时，你如何让他们继续思考？嗯，首先，你必须让他们习惯那种高度亢奋的状态。所以这是一个很长的时间段。我的意思是，我们在谈论，这将需要几年的我们所谓的周期化训练，才能让运动员达到体能巅峰。一旦你到了那里，或者在这个过程中，你可以做的是增加一些训练，即运动员达到那个水平后要做的大脑训练。例如，我可以创造一个情况，让运动员的心率达到200。这并不容易，也不好玩。你不会想成为那种人。
knowing exactly what you're doing technically, strategically and everything else. To get to that point, it's not easy. It's nothing that we can sit around and talk about. It's nothing that I can really sit here and kind of help you like a traditional psychologist would. To tell you the truth, I've got to get you to be really physical. And I've got to train your body to tolerate the lactic acid that your body generates as I get you to that profile.
但一旦你到了那里，我可以让你做填字游戏。或者我们过去常做的事情之一是，我们过去让人绕着跑道冲刺800米，一旦他们离开跑道，就要解开上面有结的巨大的绳子，做这件事绝对令人沮丧。但你知道，你必须应对这种沮丧
How do you get athletes as a coach to actually keep thinking when their bodies are in the state of hyperarousal? Well, first of all, you have to get them to be used to be that state of hyperarousal. So there's a long period of time. I mean, we're talking, it'll take several years of what we call periodized training to get an athlete to be at peak physical condition. Once you're there or along the way you're there, what you can do is then add in some drills, cognitive drills for athletes to do once they're at that level. So for example, I can create a situation where I'll get an athlete's hard rate up to 200. It's not easy, it's not fun. You don't want to be that person.
当你的心率达到每分钟200次来完成这个微小的复杂认知任务时。我发现非常迷人的一件事是，奥运会的很大一部分其实发生在电视镜头看不到的地方。所以运动员必须做好准备，他们必须热身。事实上，仅仅到达比赛现场本身就是一场斗争，特别是如果你在第一天比赛的话。嗯，你完全说得对，因为大多数观看这些体育赛事的公众，他们是
But once you're there, I can have you do a crossword puzzle. Or one of the things that we used to do is we used to have people run around a track sprinting the 800 meters around the track and once they come off the track, untidy humongous ropes with knots in them, which is entirely frustrating to do. But you know, you got to deal with the frustration
顺便说一句，太棒了，没有我们的粉丝我们就不在这里了，但大多数公众只是打开电视，可以看到这种巅峰表现，而比赛实际上可能是运动员担心的第三件事。也许它是主要事情，但它总是第三件事。我们总是担心的一件事，第一件事就是控制体重。因为在柔道中，你有一个体重级别。所以，每个人都是，我们称之为日常体重。每个人的日常体重都更重
when your heart is going at 200 beats a minute to do this little complex cognition task. One of the things that I'm fine so fascinating is that so much of the Olympics actually happens out of sight of the TV cameras. So athletes have to get ready, they have to warm up. In fact, just getting to your competition itself can be a struggle, especially if you're competing on day one. Well, you're exactly right, because most of the public who watch these sports, who are
比他们的体重级别要重。所以在称重之前，你必须制定一个计划来减重到一定数量。然后你，每个人都有一套常规来减重以进行称重。这可不是什么好玩的减重。数量，然后你，每个人都有一套常规来减重以进行称重。这可不是什么好玩的减重。和20个挨饿的人在一起可不好玩。如果你不得不处于饥饿模式一周、十天，无论那是多长时间，那都是一个
great, by the way, we wouldn't be here without our fans, but most of the public just turns on the TV and can see this peak performance and competition really is maybe the third thing that the athletes are worrying about. Maybe it's the main thing, but it's always the third thing. The first thing that we're always worrying about, number one is making weight. Because in judo, you got a weight division. And so, and everyone is, we call it walking around weight. Everyone's walking around weight is heavier
痛苦的经历。不，有些人比其他人更能应对，但这并不是你在大部分时间里想要用你的生活做的事情。所以这是运动员首先考虑的事情。第二件是什么？第二件事是时差。所以奥运会在里约，如果你来自我住的地方，也就是旧金山，你距离那里四个小时，所以你必须考虑四个小时的时差。
than what their weight division is. So you got to be on a program to cut down to a certain amount right before you're weighing in. Then you, everyone's got a routine to cut to weigh in. And it's not fun cutting weight. an amount right before you're weighing in, then you, everyone's got a routine to cut to weigh in. And it's not fun cutting weight. And it's not fun being with 20 people who are starving themselves. And if you have to be in starvation mode for a week, 10 days, whatever that is, it's a
如果奥运会是在雅典，就像2004年那样，现在我们谈论的是10个小时的时差。奥运会将在2020年东京举行，现在我们谈论的是9小时的时差。奥运会将在2020年东京举行，现在如果我们身处旧金山，我们谈论的是相反方向的9小时时差。这些都是巨大的差异，因为如果你在谈论巅峰表现，你希望人们得到休息、营养充足、精神状态达到巅峰。如果你在第一天比赛，而你想参加开幕式，这就尤其困难。
miserable experience. No, some people do that better than others, but it's not the thing that you think that you want to be doing with your life in most of the time. So that's the first thing that the athlete is thinking about. What's the second? The second thing is the jet lag. So the Olympics are in Rio, and if you're coming from where I live, which is San Francisco, you're four hours away, and so you have to think about the four-hour difference.
人们对开幕式不了解的一点是，无论主办国在哪里，它通常在午夜左右结束，每个人都必须登上当地委员会安排的巴士，那简直是一片混乱。那简直就像个动物园，很多运动员都迷路了。巴士不知道去哪里，所以你可能在12点上车，然后可能在凌晨3点回到村里，而你可能在早上6点有称重时间。
If the Olympics were in Athens, like they were in 2004, now we're talking about a 10-hour difference. Olympics are going to be in Tokyo in 2020, and now we're talking about nine-hour difference Olympics are going to be in Tokyo in 2020 now we're talking about nine hour difference the other way if you're in San Francisco and These are big differences because if you're talking about peak performance You want people to be rested well fed well in peak mental condition And it's especially difficult if you're competing on day one and you want to be in the opening ceremonies And the thing that people don't know about the opening ceremonies is it usually ends around midnight wherever the host country is,
所以很明显，如果你那样做，它会在某种程度上搞砸你的比赛。事实证明，飞往东方和飞往西方去参加比赛并不是一回事。在某些情况下，如果你碰巧朝一个方向飞行而不是另一个方向，对人体会更好。是的，事实上朝一个方向走比另一个方向更容易，因为我们的身体天生更适合在25小时的周期而不是24小时的周期内运作。这就是为什么对我们来说，熬夜比早起更容易。而这转化为旅行就是，当我们向西旅行时，我们的时区变得
and everyone's got to get on a bus that the local committee sets up, and it's just chaos. It's just a zoo, so many athletes get lost. Buses don't know where to go, and so you might get on your bus at 12 o'clock and you might be back in the village at 3 a.m., and you might have a 6am way in time.
更晚了。所以我们不是——我们只需要晚睡一会儿。我们只需要晚睡一会儿。我们只需要晚睡一会儿。这就更容易了。当我们向东旅行时，就像我从旧金山来，而我在这里的时间更晚了。是的，晚睡一会儿。这更容易，当我们向东旅行时，就像我从旧金山来，而现在我在华盛顿特区。那是三个小时的时差。
And so obviously if you did that it kind of screws you up for that competition. It turns out that flying east and flying west to get to the games is not the same thing. That in some ways it's better for the human body if you happen to be flying in one direction rather than the other. Yes, in fact it's easier to go in one direction rather than another because our bodies are built to function better on a 25-hour cycle than a 24-hour cycle. That's why it's easier for us to stay up longer than it is to get up earlier. And how that translates to travel is, when we travel west, our time zones are getting
所以今天早上我必须在七点钟到达某个地方，那是我时间的四点钟，这意味着我不得不按照我的时间三点钟起床，这更困难。所以是的，我们把这类因素考虑在内。你知道，我认为当没有去过那里的人想到奥运会时，它看起来非常迷人、非常有趣，你知道，你在这个世界舞台上，
later. So we're not- We just have to stay up a little bit later. We just have to stay up a little bit later. We just have to stay up a little bit later. And that's easier. When we travel east, like I came from San Francisco and here I am later. Yeah, stay up a little later. And that's easier when we travel east, like I came from San Francisco and here I am in DC now. That's a three hour time zone.
每个人都在看着你，每个人都在为你欢呼，每个人都希望你做得很好，当你成功时他们为你鼓掌，你处于巅峰状态，这似乎是你生命中、教练组生命中等等一段辉煌的时光。当你身处其中时，实际感觉真的是这样吗？
So this morning I had to be at a certain place at seven o'clock, which is four o'clock my time, which means I had to get up at three o'clock my time, which is more difficult. So yes, it's, we take these kinds of factors into account. You know, I think when people think about the Olympics who haven't been there, it seems very glamorous, very fun, you know, you're on this world stage,
嗯，我不能代表其他人。我必须说，在我去过的四届奥运会和十二届世界锦标赛中，我从未感到过那种辉煌的时刻，因为作为教练组成员，首先，直到每个人都完成比赛，你的情绪才算结束。不幸的是，我从未遇到过我的团队中每个人都获得金牌的情况。如果发生了那种情况，那么我认为比赛结束后，一切都是辉煌的。但无论我们的团队做得多么好，无论是我的本地团队还是奥运团队或我们正在谈论的任何团队，
everyone's watching you, everyone's cheering for you, everyone's hoping that you do well, and they clap for you when you succeed, and you're at peak performance, and it seems like it's sort of a glorious time in your life, in the life of the coaching staff, and so on. Is that how it actually feels when you're there?
如果有一个人没有成功，你知道，如果有一个人没有得到他们想要的，我能感受到。我可以让9名队员去拼搏，如果其中一人拿了银牌，我当然很高兴，但这种感觉对我来说挥之不去。我认为这对很多人来说都是真的。我给你举个好例子，2008年我女儿入选奥运代表队时。在奥运选拔赛上，她在决赛中的竞争对手是我道场的另一位女性。所以作为柔道教练，你的两名队员进入了奥运选拔赛的决赛。你知道，你赢定了，因为无论谁赢，你道场的人都会去
Well, I can't speak for everybody else. I got to say that I never felt that glorious times in the four Olympics and the 12 world championships that I've been to because as a coaching staff member, first of all, you're not done with your feelings until everyone's done competing. And unfortunately, I never had the situation where everyone on my team got a gold medal. And if that happened, then I think after the competition, everything is glorious. But no matter how good our team did, whether it's my local team or the Olympic team or whatever teams we're talking about,
并成为奥运代表队成员。但其中一位竞争对手是你的女儿。其中一个是我的女儿，另一个是我视如己出的学生。最重要的是，当我们在比赛时，我没有女儿，我只有一个队员。其中一个是我的女儿，另一个是我视如己出的学生。最重要的是，当我们在比赛时，我没有女儿，我只有一个队员。你知道，我女儿知道这一点，我们都知道，我在比赛中对待我女儿就像对待其他人一样。现在比赛结束后，她，你知道，她是我的女儿。但当我们在比赛时，她只是另一个队员，我必须像对待其他人一样对待她。所以无论如何，我们有这两名队员对阵，我对此百感交集。你知道，当我女儿赢了时，我为她感到高兴，但我为我另一个失败的队员感到非常难过。
if there's one person that didn't make it, you know, if there's one person that didn't get what they wanted, I felt it. I could have nine players take a go and if one person took a silver, of course I'm happy, but it lingers for me. I think that's true for a lot of people. And I'll give you a good example of this when my daughter made the Olympic team in 2008. At the Olympic trials, her competitor in the finals was another woman from my dojo. And so as a judo instructor, you have two of your players in the finals of the Olympic trials. You know, you're golden because no matter who wins, someone from your dojo is going to
所以，在那之后，这是一种苦乐参半的事情。我有过这种经历。是的，我的意思是，作为一个父母，我不想从我女儿身上夺走任何东西。如果我可以把我的感觉完全作为父母来划分，是的，很好。我很高兴。但没有人能百分之百地划分，我也做不到。所以，作为父母，我感觉很好，作为教练，我感觉又好又坏，这是一种复杂的心情，我至今仍然有这种感觉。
go and be on the Olympic team. But one of the competitors as your daughter. One of them is my daughter and the other one is my student who I treat like a daughter. And on top of that, when we're in competition, I don't have a daughter, I have a daughter. One of one of them is my daughter and the other one is my student who I treat like a daughter. And on top of that when we're in competition, I don't have a daughter, I have a player. You know, and my daughter knew that and we all knew that and I treated my daughter like anybody else in competition. Now after competition, she, you know, she's my daughter. But when we're in competition, she's another player and I got to treat her like I treat everybody else. And so anyway, we have these two players coming up and I have mixed feelings about that. You know, when my daughter won, I was happy for her, but I was very sad for my other player
我现在对此记忆犹新。当你现在看奥运会时，假设你不在奥运会现场，假设你不会去，你要去里约吗？不。好吧，所以当你现在在电视上观看奥运会时，假设你不在奥运会现场，假设你不会去，你要去里约吗？不。好吧。所以当你现在在电视上观看奥运会时，你在看什么？作为一个研究过奥运会的心理学家、作为教练指导过奥运会的教练、作为奥运会选手的父母，你所知道的一切，你关注的是什么？
who lost. So, after that, it was a very bitter sweet thing to have. I have occurred. And yeah, I mean, I don't want to take anything from my daughter as a parent. If I could compartmentalize my feeling solely as a parent, yeah, great. I'm happy. But no one can compartmentalize 100% where I couldn't. And so, as a parent, I feel good, as an instructor, I felt good and bad, and it's mixed up feelings that one had, and I still have it to this day.
你现在寻找什么？说实话，我看了很多东西，当我看到任何类型的巅峰表现时，它不一定非得是体育。甚至当我看着舞者或擅长做一件很难做的事情的人时，他们让它看起来如此轻松。而我自动会想到汗水、眼泪、鲜血以及为了做到我们所看到的毫不费力的那一幕，那个人付出的多年的汗水、眼泪、鲜血和努力。当你参加比赛时，你谈论的是，你知道，几分钟、一小时，背后是多年的准备，你无法将你的记忆从这些年的准备中剥离出来，这些事情实际上让我感到不知所措。
I remember it very clearly right now. When you watch the Olympics now, and let's say you're not at the Olympics, let's say you're not going to, are you going to Rio? No. Okay, so when you watch the Olympics now and let's say you're not at the Olympics, let's say you're not going to, are you going to Rio? No. Okay. So when you watch the Olympics on television now, what is it that you're watching? What is it that you pay attention to knowing all that you know as a psychologist who studied the Olympics as a coach, who's coached to the Olympics as a parent at the Olympics?
所以当你在想运动员时，你实际上在想所有这些，那些我们在电视上看不到的时刻，所有早上四点钟醒来、在周末练习、放弃生活其他方面的时刻，不仅是为了那些获胜的人，也是为了那里所有的其他人。绝对的。我的意思是，每个人都做出了巨大的牺牲。当然，队员或运动员永远是头号牺牲者，但想想他们所有的支持人员。对我们来说，我们垫子上的每一个队员，背后都有一个10人或20人的支持团队，只为了把那个人送上垫子，所以一个人背后有一支军队，每个人都在同一个
What do you look for now? I look at a lot of things to take a truth and when I see peak performance of any type doesn't have to be sports. Even when I look at dancers or somebody who's really good at doing something that's difficult to do, they make it look so easy. And I automatically think about the sweat and the tears and the blood and the effort about the sweat and the tears and the blood and the effort for years that that person put in to be able to do that that we saw that was just effortless. When you're at competition, you're talking about, you know, a few minutes, an hour of years of preparation and you can't divorce your memories from those years of preparation, those things overwhelm me actually.
团队里，他们从不分享聚光灯，他们从不获得闪光灯，他们只是分享着他们帮助这个人取得巅峰表现的知识。当这个人获胜时，每个人都感觉很好，而当这个人失败时，每个人都感觉糟糕透顶。当我看到这些事情时，我的心其实是向着所有这些人以及运动员的。戴维·莫特莫，我想感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。我的荣幸。谢谢你。本期《隐藏的大脑》由克里斯·班德拉耶夫制作，珍妮·施密特编辑。
And so when you're thinking about the athletes, you're actually thinking about all of those, the times that we're not seeing on television, all of the waking up at four o'clock in the morning and practicing on the weekends and giving up other aspects of your life, and not just for the people who win, but also for everybody else who's there. Absolutely. I mean, everyone's made a huge sacrifice. And of course, the player or the athlete is always the number one sacrificeer but think about all their support staff. For us for every player that we had on the mat we had a support team of 10 or 20 just to get that person on the mat and so behind one person there's an army and everyone's on the same
我们的员工还包括卡拉姆·阿卡尔·卡拉辛、玛吉·潘曼和马克斯·纳斯德拉克。你可以在推特、脸书和Instagram上关注我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这很有帮助。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
team and they never share the limelight they never get the spotlight they just share in the knowledge that they help this person have a peak performance. When that person wins, everyone feels good and when that person loses, everyone feels awful. It's all those people, as well as the athletes, that my heart actually reaches out to when I see these things. David Montemore, I want to thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. thank you. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Chris Banderayev, and edited by Jenny Schmitt.
团队，他们从不分享风头，从不获得聚光灯，他们只是共享着帮助这个人达到巅峰状态的认知。当这个人获胜时，每个人都感觉很好；而当这个人失利时，每个人都感觉糟糕透顶。当我看到这些事情时，我的心其实是向所有这些人以及运动员伸出的。大卫·蒙特莫尔（David Montemore），我想感谢你今天来到《隐藏的心智》（Hidden Brain）。不客气，谢谢你。本期《隐藏的心智》由克里斯·班德拉耶夫（Chris Banderayev）制作，珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmitt）编辑。
Our staff also includes Karam Akkar Kalasin, Maggie Panman, and Max Nassdrak. You can follow us on Twitter, Facebook, and Instagram, and listen to my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, give us a review. It helps. I'm Shankar Vedaantum, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的工作人员还包括卡拉姆·阿卡尔·卡拉辛（Karam Akkar Kalasin）、玛吉·潘曼（Maggie Panman）和马克斯·纳斯德拉克（Max Nassdrak）。您可以在推特、脸书和Instagram上关注我们，并在您当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果您喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这很有帮助。我是尚卡尔·维丹图姆（Shankar Vedaantum），这是美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。